[Music]
here's your money briefing for Tuesday
June 6th I'm J.R Whelan for the Wall
Street Journal
millions of workers have 401k accounts
to put money away for retirement but is
that enough Wall Street Journal
contributor Michael Pollock joins us
with the pros and cons of opening up an
IRA in addition to your 401k so first of
all Michael what's the difference
between a 401K retirement account and an
IRA and how do they allow people to
invest so a 401K retirement account is
an account offered through your employer
the employer usually deducts money from
each paycheck and that money is invested
in an account on your behalf
the employer designs the account
determines what the Investments are in
the account and it's a fairly smooth
process most people don't even really
pay a lot of attention to where the
money is going in the 401K and as a
result of it being so easy it's a great
way for people to save up money for
eventual retirement an IRA or individual
retirement account on the other hand is
an account that is not held necessarily
through an employer anyone can have an
IRA you can have one even if you're not
working and the IRA does not have a set
menu of Investments people have to
decide on their own where the money in
the ira is going to be invested they
have to choose the funds or the ETFs or
whatever they want to put the IRA money
into and there's no regulation that
would prevent someone from having an IRA
alongside their 401K that's right
there's no reason why you can't have
both both so what's the advantage of
contributing to two retirement plans at
the same time in the 401K plan the IRS
limits your annual employee
contributions to twenty two thousand
five hundred dollars for people who are
less than 50 years of age there's also a
limit on how much you can put into an
IRA in a year and that's
6500 for someone who is under 50 years
of age but if you only contribute to the
401K plan you're obviously putting away
less money than you would if you
contributed to both if you take the
twenty two thousand five hundred dollars
that you contribute to the 401K and you
add the six thousand five hundred
dollars that you're contributing to an
IRA that's essentially almost 30 percent
more per year and the other thing is the
IRS from time to time increases those
limits so over time you could be
contributing more and are there
disadvantages to having to retire
government accounts going at the same
time well it makes more work for someone
who wants to keep an eye on both
accounts because the choices are are so
Broad in an IRA someone really has to
think a little bit about how they want
to invest that money there is a
possibility also of racking up more fees
or more trading costs if you have an IRA
so you have to think a little bit about
how you're going to invest that money in
a cost efficient way so we're talking
about IRAs and 401ks we often hear a lot
about Roth IRAs and some companies are
now allowing workers to open up Roth
401ks how do those differ from
traditional IRAs and 401ks and why would
someone consider those well so the
biggest difference between the
traditional IRA and the Roth IRA is the
type of money that you're contributing
with a traditional IRA the money is on a
pre-tax basis which means that when you
eventually start taking withdrawals from
that Ira that money is going to be taxed
your ordinary income rate with a Roth
IRA Europe contributing after tax money
so that's money you've already paid tax
on and if you follow the IRS rules to
the letter by the time you retire then
that money can come out possibly
tax-free and the advantage of that is
that if you have a large 401k plan and
also a sizable Ira if you're taking the
required minimum distributions which are
what the monies are known as after you
retire starting to withdraw on those
accounts you could have a sizable tax
liability and you don't really have a
lot of control over how much income
you're getting from those two different
accounts but on the other hand if you
have a Roth IRA and a 401k then the
money you take out of the Roth IRA is
not being taxed in your overall tax
liability could be lower oh so more
money in your pocket that's right and
you also have more flexibility about how
much in distributions you're taking
because with a Roth IRA you don't have
any required minimum distributions
now there's this other newer account
called a Roth 401k that more and more
companies have started offering and
those are very similar to a Roth IRA
right now they do have required minimum
distributions but that's going to change
under the law in 2024 there will not be
required minimum distributions so a Roth
401k plan also could be advantageous in
the sense that it will mean a lower tax
liability after you retire now what if
someone doesn't have a 401k maybe
because they work part-time or they're
self-employed what retirement plans
should they consider to maximize the
retirement savings well there could be a
lot of people in that situation a
traditional IRA or a Roth IRA would
probably make the most sense there the
Roth IRA is very popular among advisors
advisors really think that a Roth IRA
could be the best choice there aside
from the fact that there aren't any
required minimum distributions in
retirement there also is more
flexibility about your withdrawals from
a Roth IRA which you might be able to do
even before retirement depending on the
situation all right that's Wall Street
Journal contributor Michael Pollock and
that's your money briefing I'm J.R
Whalen for the Wall Street Journal
foreign